ازمه جديده تلوح في الافق بين فرنسا
وروسيا والسبب دول القرن الافريقي حيث
اتهم الرئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون روسيا
بتغذيه دعايه مناهضه لفرنسا في افريقيا
لخدمه طموحاتها اذا استخدم ماكرون عباره
ان روسيا تريد دول افريقيا والتهامها
محملا روسيا سبب فشل التدخل العسكري في
مالي كجزء من عمليه مكافحه الارهاب وبانها
كانت سبب في تراجع النفوذ العسكريه
الفرنسي في المنطقه الافريقيه في اشاره
طبعا الى التدخل مرتزقه في مالي بعد
الانقلاب الذي حدث مؤخرا وقال بان عدد من
القوى التابعه لروسيا والتي تريد نشر نفوذ
في افريقيا تتهم فرنسا باستغلال علاقاتها
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه في مستعمراتها
السابقه فقط للاذاء والاذاء فرنسا
والاضرار بها وبان روسيا تسعى الافتراس
الدول الافريقيه المطربه همم في اشاره الى
ان روسيا قامت بناشر مجموعه مقولات
العسكريه الخاصه فيها وادي النيجر جروب في
العديد من البلدان بما في ذلك جمهوريه
افريقيا الوسطى ومالي
[موسيقى]